[Applause]
a dream come true i mean you are really
freaking people out they love your
videos i know i can't believe it's been
the best year of my life seriously i'm
so honored to do it what like even made
you come up with this idea oh it's so
funny so i am a snacker through and
through and i love a midnight snack the
most so um it was just like one night i
opened the fridge i did like classic
refrigerator open and i was like what
can i make and i saw i had these
crescent rolls and i was like you know
what let's see what i can kind of pack
these with and just try a bunch out and
we brought the best ones for you today
that i love but yeah just to find like
that you know if it's okay i wanted to
invite someone to this party oh i love
guests you do let's do it okay well
she's one of my favorite people and um
we're lucky enough that she's gonna join
us please welcome back to the show the
beautiful and talented vanessa hudgens
i just want to squeeze you so badly
badly is so real
the
so
it's like when somebody has fleas but in
a good way yeah
yeah exactly um i'm so happy to see you
i'm so happy to see you and um zach we
are hoping that you can show us how to
make your mystery pop yes and that's the
beauty this is so simple that we could
literally have like six conversations
going on at once great and still get
through it all right i don't think i've
ever used an air fryer before oh really
yeah i'm like how does it work yeah this
is this is a gorgeous airfryer i'm um
i'm very excited to say that i actually
made this myself
um i did i designed it it's beautiful
that's what it's called beautiful
i'm just i'm psychic
zach what are we putting in the puffs so
we have um a cookie puff a fruit puff
and then we have
um a tomato and mozzarella puff
interesting yeah are you ready to get
going yes i am okay let's let's do it
okay so the first one we have here is a
milano cookie so what you're gonna do is
just put it on the triangle
and just roll the crescent so yeah let's
put it right in the airfryer tail we
won't put it on yet but we'll just get
it set up like we want
the um yeah right in there and then
after that we're going to move on to um
the cantaloupe
i'm not very comfortable in the kitchen
can you tell me by the way thank you
vanessa welcome to my world this is the
lucille ball kitchen i love how you're
gonna fit right in i love it this one
we're gonna do now is the cantaloupe
crescent roll and really quickly did you
i don't know you probably both do you
know how to i don't know do you know how
to cut a cantaloupe no do you i mean uh
here's what i would do with okay good i
would just cut it down the middle no
you're you're honestly on the right
track right there i'm gonna be honest
with you i am
not what i was expecting no well i think
too i think since well some of us aren't
comfortable in the kitchen um no some of
us have this thing i like to call i
don't know we like melon anxiety because
we're just like so scared to like buy a
full melon ever and i've realized that
like this is simply just cutting off the
ends slicing it down the middle and
there it is um and this one is going to
be the most intensive here and it's
seriously on not even so grab your olive
oil a little drizzle don't be scared um
and then from there you're just gonna
grab your seasoning and just do a little
pinch of it right over everything what
kind of seasoning is this oh good
question so we're doing garlic powder
crushed red pepper salt and oregano
oh and then from here it's really simple
so we're going to grab our little knives
and you guys can do it the way that you
want to um we're just going to basically
kind of line this top region right here
um a tip i learned also if you're having
a hard time and you're cutting a tiny
little thing and it's like not really
going through and you have a dull knife
do a little
pokey
and then your knife will go nicely right
into it nice and it will open
i have a lot of dull knives
me too me too
really i feel like with how you smash
that into the board you and sharp knives
are like best friends i uh i need to get
a knife sharpener roll it
wow
that knife was sharp that was sharp
right there we got it okay there we go
i can't
place it right in there so from here um
what you would do is you were going to
close this you're going to put it in at
300 degrees for five minutes take your
tongs kind of toss them around a little
bit so they don't stick so one of the
things that i wanted to do with this
design was like a sleeker technological
design we're only moving forward into
the future
um so here it's all a touch screen so
i'm going to touch it everything
i'm going to play airfry
uh zechariah 300 for this one
[Music]
[Applause]
how long zachariah five minutes on this
first round
350 you said 300 oh it's okay
and then airfry
hit that
vanessa's killing it over here i'm doing
well in the kitchen
all right now we're going to taste them
because tv magic says we have beautiful
ones right here we can all take ours
yeah and put it over here because that's
sort of the funnest part
um should we start with the milanos yeah
absolutely all right
oh
you know i got it i love it it's like a
chocolate croissant well do you what do
you think about this one i want to rank
them i think it's more fun that way if
we can rank them one time um
what i like about this
is that a one out of ten yeah well just
be honest i i think it's
like it was good it's not like giving
a hundred percent
um
i'm gonna give it a six yeah that's fair
i tried i got excited i tried the
cantaloupe oh no let's go for it we're
going forward we're moving forward
let's do it oh i think i know where
you're headed with this one wait you're
not loving are you living i'm not i
don't
i'm not loving as much i hate it
[Applause]
i'm going to defend this real quick okay
go for it go for it
this is tv magic if it was fresh out
that air fryer let me tell you
transported to the south of france it's
that is effervescent it's buttery it's
great heat makes a big difference and
those are not hot hot
thank you okay so last one we'll cut it
in half this one's chunky i like that
i can get down with this
it tastes how i wanted it to taste
and we said it for last for an obvious
reason yeah no this is a classic i need
like a glass of wine sit down with him
don't play with me give me a book
but this is where i'm going in for the
second bite oh god you know i love this
one so this one i would rate it 10. yeah
10. and um by the way today
everyone in our audience is gonna go
home with a beautiful air fryer
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
they come in four colors as you saw
i'm super proud of these um and um
they're exclusive um and available at
walmart as is the whole line and
walmart.com but you are going home with
them
today thank you oh my god
[Music]
you